check out this week's must-see movies  it's my sister you're having a Christmas  party tonight an office manager throws  an epic rager to save his failing  company in the holiday comedy office  Christmas party these dreams that we  keep running into each other maybe it  means something I doubt it yeah from the  creator of whiplash comes lala land a  romantic musical that will have your  toes tapping people like to believe in  fairy attacks the biographical drama  Jackie explores the icons life in the  wake of the Kennedy assassination if you  split the storm there won't be another  camera here's this week's fan tissa  patient  [Music]  so what's your weekend to get going to  be let us know by commenting below see  you next time on weekend ticket  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]